THEY'RE HERE TO SHARE SOME NEWS.
THEY WILL JOIN ME FOR NEWS ABOUT
NEWSGUARD LATER THIS HOUR.
>>> FIRST, THE NEVER-ENDING
ELECTION.
NEVERENDING ELECTIONS ARE SO BAD
FOR THE UNITED STATES.
AS PRESIDENT BIDEN HITS HIS
ONE-YEAR MARK IN OFFICE, DONALD
TRUMP HITS A WALL, REPEATING HIS
USUAL LIES AT A RALLY IN ARIZONA
OVERNIGHT.
THE RALLIES THEMSELVES ARE
BARELY NEWS ANYMORE.
WHAT'S NEWSWORTHY, WHAT'S
INTERESTING, IS THE WAY THESE
ALLIES ARE COVERED OR THE WAY
THEY'RE IGNORED.
FOR EXAMPLE, HERE'S WHAT TRUMP
SAID AT THE VERY TOP OF THE
RALLY SATURDAY NIGHT, CALLING
THE MEDIA THE BIG LIE.
>> LAST YEAR WE HAD A RIGGED
ELECTION AND THE PROOF IS ALL
OVER THE PLACE.
WE HAVE A LOT OF PROOF AND THEY
KNOW IT'S PROOF.
THEY ALWAYS TALK ABOUT THE BIG
LIE.
THEY'RE THE BIG LIE.
BUT THE FAKE NEWS AND THE
LAME-STREAM MEDIA REFUSE AND
REFUSE, THEY REFUSE TO TALK
ABOUT IT.
>> SO HE'S ACTUALLY RIGHT ABOUT
THAT.
MAJOR NETWORKS AND NEWSROOMS
MOSTLY DO IGNORE TRUMP'S LIES.
ABC MORNING SHOW, NO MENTION OF
THE RALLY.
NBC, NO MENTION OF THE RALLY.
EVEN "FOX & FRIENDS" ONLY
MENTIONED TRUMP A COUPLE OF
TIMES.
FOX DID NOT HYPE THE RALLY IN
ADVANCE, AIR IT LIVE, DID NOT
PLAY ALL OF THE GRATZEST HITS
AFTERWARDS.
THEY'RE BUSY BIDEN BASHING.
SO FANS HAD TO SEEK OUT NEWSMAX
AND OA TO GET THEIR FIX.
THEY TREATED FANS LIKE A SUPER
BOWL WITH HOURS OF PREGAME
COVERAGE AND LIVE INTERVIEWS
FROM THE SAND.
AND THIS TRUMP REPORTER ALMOST
NAILED IT WITH ALMOST A CULT
FOLLOWING.
>> WHY DOES DONALD TRUMP HAVE
SUCH A STRONG FOLLOWING, IT'S
ALMOST LIKE A CULT FOLLOWING
LIKE NO OTHER PRESIDENT EVER
HAD?
>> THE TRUTH ABOUT CULT'S
FOLLOWING IS IT'S A VERY NARROW
PLACE IN AMERICA.
MOST ARIZONANS WERE NOT RUSHING
TO THE RALLY.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF AMERICANS
DON'T CARE ENOUGH ABOUT POLITICS
TO SPEND THEIR SATURDAY NIGHT
LISTENING TO A FORMER PRESIDENT
RANT AND RAVE.
MOST DID NOT CARE OR GIVE ONE
HOOT.
BUT FOR MAGA DIE-HARD WHO WANT
TO WATCH, THERE ARE DIE-HARDS
STANDING AND FIGHTING FOR A
CHANCE.
AND THEY FILL HALF THE SCREEN IN
A SPEECH.
TRUMP IS FREE CONTENT FOR THESE
CHANNELS AND HE PROMOTES THEM IN
TURN.
ONE OF THE CHANNELS, ONE AMERICA
NEWS, IS IN TROUBLE THIS
MORNING.
THE BIGGEST SOURCE OF REVENUE,
DIRECTV, IS DROPPING THE
CONSPIRACY CHANNEL IN A COUPLE
OF MONTHS.
DIRECTV SAID THIS IS A ROUTINE
DECISION BUT ON THE FAR RIETZ
IT'S BEING CAST AS A CONSPIRACY
TO BANISH DISSENTING VOICES.
THE REALITY IS ONE AMERICA NEWS
IS THERE'S VERY LITTLE NEWS.
THEY DON'T HAVE NEWSROOMS AROUND
THE WORLD.
IT'S MOSTLY A PROPAGANDA
CHANNEL, PROMOTING A CONSPIRACY
AND THE NEXT.
BUT HE SAID HE WAS AT THE RALLY
WITH AT&T AFTER THE SHOW AND
IT'S INTERESTING BECAUSE AT&T
SPUN OFF DIRECTV AND IS IN THE
PROCESS OF DISBANDING FROM CNN.
BUT PRESIDENT TRUMP SUGGESTED
THEY SHOULD CHANGE TO AT&T.
YOU KNOW, A LOT OF TIMES THE
NEWS MEDIA, PEOPLE TALK ABOUT
THE SIZE OF THE CROWD AND
PORTRAYING TRUMP STRONG AND
POWERFUL, BUT I THINK HIS
RALLIES ARE BECOMING A SHOW OF
W
WEAKNESS.
TELLS HIS FANS THEY SHOULD DROP
AT&T.
WILL NOT HAPPEN, NEVER HAS
BEFORE.
CERTAINLY A SMALL NUMBER DO TUNE
INTO FRINGE CHANNELS IF THEY CAN
FIND THEM SOMEWHERE, BUT WHEN
EVEN FOX REFUSES TO CARRY A
TRUMP RALLY AT THE START OF THE
MIDTERM YEAR, YOU KNOW SOMETHING
GOING ON, THAT'S NOT STRENGTH,
THAT'S A WEAKNESS FROM THE
CURRENT PRESIDENT.
NOW THE CURRENT PRESIDENT, WE
WILL HEAR FROM HIM AS BIDEN
HOLDS HIS FIRST FORMAL PRESS
CONFERENCE SINCE NONKVEMBER.
I WANT TO GET INTO THAT WITH MY
TWO POLITICAL ANALYSTS, ALYSSA
AND JOE LOCKHART.
WELCOME TO YOU BOTH.
ALYSSA, DID YOU WATCH THE TRUMP
RALLY?
>> NO, LIKE MOST AMERICANS I WAS
WATCHING THE PATRIOTS AND BILLS
GAME.
I WAS KIND OF SURPRISED THEY
WOULD DECIDE TO HOST THIS BIG
COMING BACK RALLY FOR DONALD
TRUMP WHEN THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY IS WANTING TO WATCH THIS
EXCITING FOOTBALL GAME.
BUT TO YOUR POINT, BRIAN, YES,
THE FORMER PRESIDENT HAS LOST
STEAM IN LEGACY MEDIA.
BUT WHAT I WOULD NOT DISCREDIT
IS HOW MUCH THESE SRTORT OF
FRINGER SITES, WHETHER IT'S
STEVE BANNON'S WAR ROOM, OAN,
NEWSMAX, THAT PEOPLE ARE STILL
TUNING IN AND WE ARE GOING TO
REGRET IT IF WE THINK HE'S NOT
COMING BACK AND WE DON'T PREPARE
ACCORDINGLY AND WE DON'T COVER
THESE INCREDIBLE, TERRIFYING
LIES HE WAS SPOUTING LAST NIGHT.
THOSE DO WARRANT GETTING
COVERAGE BECAUSE IT SHOWS YOU
WHAT HE'S PLANNING TO DO IN THE
MONTHS AHEAD, THE YEAR AHEAD.
HE'S STILL STOKING THE LIES
ABOUT THE ELECTION BEING STOLEN.
TO SOME DEGREE IT DOES WARRANT
NEWS MEDIA COVERAGE.
>> MY BRAIN GETS A LITTLE JAMMED
WHEN I HEAR FORMER WHITE HOUSE
COMMUNICATIONS BOSS SAY HE WAS
DELIVERING TERRIFYING LIES TO
THE CROWD.
WE'RE ONLY A YEAR OUTZ OF OF TH
PRESIDENCY AND IT SOUNDS LIKE
YOU'RE FULLY DISTURBED BY THE
PROSPECT OF A TRUMP 2024.
>> ABSOLUTELY, AND I HAVE BEEN
OUTSPOKEN ABOUT THIS.
HE RESIGNED HIS RIGHT TO EVER
SERVE AS PRESIDENT AGAIN AFTER
JANUARY 6th.
AND LYING TO THE PUBLIC ABOUT
THE FUNDAMENTALS OF OUR
DEMOCRACY AND THE FACT WE HAD A
LEGITIMATE ELECTION AND JOE
BIDEN LEGITIMATELY WON IS BEYOND
DESTRUCTIVE TO THE FUTURE OF
THIS COUNTRY.
REPUBLICANS, MY PARTY CANNOT
DISMISS THAT.
THEY CANNOT DISCREDIT IT.
HE'S GOING TO CONTINUE TO STOKE
THESE LIES AND IT WILL BE OUR
UNDOING IF WE'RE NOT PAYING
ATTENTION AND TAKING HIM VERY
SERIOUSLY WHEN HE TALKS ABOUT,
YOU KNOW, WANTING TO STACK STATE
OFFICIALS SO THAT IN THE FUTURE,
ELECTORS ARE GOING TO GO FOR
HIM.
HE'S DOING THIS ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY.
WE NEED TO BE PAYING ATTENTION
TO IT.
>> JOE, WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF WHAT
ALYSSA SAID ABOUT THE BALANCE OF
HOW MUCH ATTENTION IS PAID AT
THESE RALLIES OR NOT?
>> I THINK THE RALLIES AND
DONALD TRUMP NEEDS TO BE PAID
ATTENTION TO BECAUSE HE STILL
HAS A STRANGLEHOLD ON THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
THESE THINGS AROUND THE COUNTRY
ARE UNDERMINING OUR DEMOCRACY IN
PLAIN SIGHT, RIGHT IN FRONT OF
US.
THEY DON'T GET THE ATTENTION
THEY DESERVE BECAUSE PEOPLE KIND
OF DISMISS THEM.
THEY SHOULD NOT BE DISMISSED.
THIS IS OUR DEMOCRACY WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT.
AND I WILL SAY THIS ABOUT THE
LIES, THE TRUMP PARTY,
PRESIDENCY LIED FROM THE
BEGINNING FROM THE FIRST DAY AND
IT'S A HARD HABIT TO BREAK.
ALYSSA HERSELF FRIDAY TWEETED
JOE BIDEN DIDN'T NEED OR DO AN
EDUCATION PROGRAM ON
VACCINATIONS, HE WENT RIGHT FTO
MANDATES.
THAT'S ABSOLUTELY NOT TRUE.
JOE BIDEN DID MORE PROMOTING
VACCINATIONS IN THE FIRST SIX
MONTHS OF HIS PRESIDENCY THAN
ANYTHING ELSE.
>> ALL RIGHT, JOE, LET'S LET
ALYSSA RESPOND.
>> HEY, LISTEN, BRIAN, YOU GOT
ME AND JOE TO AGREE ON THE FIRST
PART OF THAT.
I FOLLOWED UP WITH THAT AND HAD
A GREAT CONVERSATION WITH RON
KLAIN.
IT WAS NOT FAIR TO A BIDEN DID
NOTHING ON VACCINATIONS.
THAT IS CERTAINLY NOT THE CASE.
I ENCURRENT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION TO PARTER IN WITH
REPUBLICAN GOVERNORS.
IF YOU HAD JOE BIDEN AND RON
DeSANTIS DO AN AD SAYING YOU CAN
TRUST THIS VACCINE, IT IS SAFE,
THAT WOULD GO SO MUCH FURTHER
THAN MANDATES WE KNEW WOULD GET
KNOCKED DOWN AT THE STATE LEVEL.
I WILL JUST SAY THAT QUICK.
BRIAN, I MENTION AS WELL AN
INTERESTING JUXTAPOSITION IN THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY LAST NIGHT WAS
THE SWEARING IN OF GOVERNOR
YOUNGKIN IN VIRGINIA.
THIS IS A MAN WHO CAME IN, MADE
SOME SMART EDUCATION REFORMS
IMMEDIATELY.
HE HONORED MARTIN LUTHER KING,
HE DID A DAY OF SERVICE AND THEN
HE MET WITH STATE LEADERS IN THE
COMMUNITY.
THAT'S WHAT MY PARTY COULD BE,
AND THE SPLIT SCREEN OF DONALD
TRUMP SPOUTING CONSPIRACY
THEORIES AND LIES AND HOSTING
FRINGE FIGURES IN ARIZONA.
IT'S A TIME FOR CHOOSING, AND
THE TIME FOR CHOOSING SHOULD
HAVE BEEN SOONER BUT WE'VE GOT
BETTER OPTIONS OUT THERE,
YOUNGKIN BEING ONE OF THEM.
I'M JUST STUNNED AFTER ALL OF
THIS THERE'S STILL SUCH A
FOLLOWING AND SUCH A
STRANGLEHOLD BY DONALD TRUMP.
>> WHEN DIRECTV IS DROPPING ONE
AMERICA NEWS AND FOX IS IG
IGNORING.
>> Translator: TRUMP'S RALLIES,
SOMETHING IS GOING ON BUT IT
WILL BE A WHILE BEFORE WE KNOW.
I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW ABOUT B
BIDEN'S ONE-YEAR MARK.
HOW DO YOU THINK THE PRESS IS
DOING ON THE ONE-YEAR MARK?
>> FIRST OFF, THE PRESS IS
FAILING.
THERE OUGHT TO BE TRUTH IN THE
WHITE HOUSE AND WE DIDN'T GET
THAT, WE DIDN'T GET THAT AT ALL.
WE RETURNED KIND OF TO THE
SNARKY INTERVIEWS WE HAD WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND TO A CERTAIN
RESPECT PRESIDENT OBAMA.
AND I WILL GIVE YOU EXAMPLES.
FROM THE VERY FIRST BRIEFING THE
TRUMP SPOKESMEN LIED, EVERY DAY,
EVERY BRIEFING.
AND JEN PSAKI IS NOW IN THERE
TELLING US THE TRUTH, TELLING US
WHAT'S GOING ON IN THE
GOVERNMENT, WHAT PEOPLE NEED TO
HEAR AND THEY'RE RARELY ON LIVE
TELEVISION.
SO THAT TELLS ME THIS IS MORE
ABOUT ENTERTAINMENT THAN IT IS
ABOUT NEWS.
IT IS MORE ABOUT GETTING VIEWERS
THAN LETTING PEOPLE KNOW WHAT'S
GOING ON IN THE COUNTRY.
AND THAT'S A FAILURE AS FAR AS
I'M CONCERNED.
S.
>> INTERESTING.
PRESS BRIEFINGS EVERY DAY, PRESS
CONFERENCES VERY IRREGULARLY.
LET'S LOOK AT THE PAST, THE FEW
PRESIDENTS WILL SHOW COMPARED TO
BIDEN.
BIDEN'S BEEN HOLDING FORMAL
PRESS CONFERENCES LESS OFTEN,
THERE'S THE DATA.
HOWEVER, HE DOES HOLD INFORMAL
Q&As QUITE OFTEN, MORE THAN PAST
PRESIDENTS, WHERE HE ANSWERS A
FEW QUESTIONS FROM THE PRESS
CORPS AFTER THE EVENT.
THAT'S THE DATA.
WE HAVE A FORMAL PRESS
CONFERENCE COMING UP THIS WEEK,
IT'S BEEN ANNOUNCED ALMOST A
WEEK AHEAD OF TIME.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THAT
STRATEGY, ALYSSA?
>> IT KIND OF GOES AGAINST MY
PR-101.
YOU JUST DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
NEWS CYCLE WILL BE SO TO
ANNOUNCE IT THIS FAR IN ADVANCE
BUILDS EXPECTATION.
BUTZ ANY TIME THE PRESIDENT IS
TALKING TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
AND THE PRESS IS A GOOD THING.
BIDEN'S CHALLENGE IS THIS, HIS
PRESS SECRETARY DOES SPEAK TO
THE PRESS DAILY.
THAT IS A GOOD THING.
BUT THEY'RE VERY CONFUSING AND
CONFLICTING GUIDANCES GOING OUT
AROUND COVID.
HE NEEDS TO BE ANSWERING THE
QUESTIONS MORE REGULARLY.
IF YOU CAN MAKE SENSE OF THE
CDC'S GUIDANCES ON QUARANTINE, I
WOULD LOVE TO HEAR THE ANSWER.
I KNOW MOST AMERICANS WHO DO
TAKE COVID V